bien sûr l'acte que nous allons poser
dans quelques instants est un acte
solennel c'est un acte grave et c'est un
acte rare nos commissions ont
méticuleusement examiner l'ensemble du
budget dépenses et recettes
l'ensemble mais nous allons et nous
avons déjà examiné en hémicycle la
partie des recettes mais nous n'irons
pas plus loin monsieur le ministre nous
n'irons pas plus loin parce que vous
êtes allé trop loin avec votre
gouvernement un budget mes chers
collègues ça n'est pas des chiffres
alignés dans des colonnes un budget ce
sont des choix c'est une politique et
ceux vos choix les choix que portent ces
budgets sont de mauvais choix et je m'en
explique parce que un budget normalement
c'est un budget qui va préparer l'avenir
alors que là vous sacrifier le long
terme au court terme l'avenir au présent
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons voulu par cet acte très rare poser
un acteur politique parce que je pense
que c'est pas la technique budgétaire de
tenir la politique c'est à la politique
au sens qu'on donne à notre action de
tenir la technique et nous avons voulu
oui sortir pour une fois du train-train
budgétaire pour affirmer un certain
nombre de vérités le vote auquel nous
allons procéder aujourd'hui c'est un
signal d' alerte un signal d'alarmé qui
ne vous est pas destinée qui est destiné
à nos compatriotes aux français pour que
tous les français sachent que la
situation n'est pas celle que vous leur
présentez vous avez parlé de malice il
ya quelques instants monsieur le
ministre franchement la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte ce n'est pas une malice
c'est une grosse blague
ce que nous visons nous ça n'est pas les
dépenses qu'a nécessité le traitement
des conséquences de la crise nous avons
souhaité rappeler bien sûr voter les
différentes lois rectificatives
ce n'est pas ça c'est cette folie
dépensière qui prend appui sur la crise
mais qui n'a rien à voir rapporteur
général nous le rappelait il ya quelques
instants avec cette crise mais alors
rien à voir ce que nous visons c'est sur
les trois dernières années une dérive
201 milliards d'euros 2 dépenses
ordinaires comme dit la cour des comptes
pas de dépenses qu'ovide leurs cornes et
chers collègues le record depuis quinze
ans ce que nous vivons est ce que nous
visons aussi c'est l'accumulation des
déficits sociaux mais aussi budgétaire
sans précédent du jamais vu qui est en
train de gonfler notre endettement et
qui est en train de faire mes chers
collègues oui de faire de la france
demain un risque systémique de l'europe
parce qu'un jour avec l'inflation en
allemagne notamment oui un jour les taux
vont remonter et alors ce sera la
catastrophe eh bien nous solennellement
nous voulons aujourd'hui avertir nos
compatriotes ce que nous visons aussi ce
sont les 42 annonce depuis cet été les
25 milliards d'euros dans ces annonces
c'est à dire 400 millions d'euros par
jour depuis le mois de septembre
annoncée par votre gouvernement
alors certes noël et à quelques
encablures mais les français sont pas
des ravis de la crèche et nous ne
voulons pas non plus qu'ils soient les
dindons de la farce monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre le budget que vous
défendez l'indéfendable parce que c'est
un budget de campagne oui de campagne
électorale la campagne électorale la
plus chère de la vème république
et si si je devais résumer par une seule
formule notre position je reprendrai je
citerai balzac oui balzac cité dans un
site dans un débat budgétaire aucune
génération aucune génération n'a le
droit d'en amoindrir une autre c'est ce
que vous faites précisément et le
sabotage ont chers collègues il est là
le sabotage du futur le sabotage de
l'avenir et des futures générations
voilà voilà un président de la
république qui nous avaient tous promis
qu'il allait tout réformer tout changer
qui a tout continue et qui n'a que six
peut réformer il est le seul depuis 30
ans à n'avoir pas assumé une vraie
réforme des retraites voilà un président
de la république qui nous avait promis
au pays une cure de jouvence un demande
nouveau et qui utilise les plus vieilles
ficelles de la classe politique depuis
40 ans toujours plus de dépenses
publiques un problème de la dépense
publique mais si c'est la dépense
publique qui devait mesurer la qualité
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
mais alors la france serait à l'avant
garde mes chers collègues du bonheur
universel bienne bien sûr et enfin voilà
un président de république qui aura
concentré entre ses mains tentent
pouvoir sous ce quinquennat jamais le
parlement n'aura été aussi affaiblie 125
amendement budgétaire du gouvernement
notamment en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien tant de
pouvoirs pour quel résultat dernier pour
les dépenses
budgétaires les dépenses publiques
dernier pour les prélèvements
obligatoires dernier pour le déficit
notamment commerciales bien sûr du mieux
sur une croissance qui est un rattrapage
voilà pour reprendre le titre d'un livre
célèbre du philosophe français marcel
gaucher je ne pense pas malheureusement
que pendant ce quinquennat emmanuel
macron aura remédié en quoi que ce soit
au malheur français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]